nos piden resolver y graficar un sistema
de ecuaciones la manera de repaso
recordemos que resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones implica encontrar los valores
de xy que cumplen con ambas ecuaciones
una manera de hacer esto es despejar una
de las variables en una de las
ecuaciones y lo que se obtenga
sustituirlo en la otra ecuación de esta
manera garantizamos que estamos
cumpliendo ambas restricciones usemos la
ecuación de abajo y menos x es igual a 5
y es directo despejar una de las
variables vamos a despejar y para eso
sumamos x a ambos lados de la ecuación
nos queda del lado izquierdo estos
términos se van y nos queda tan solo ya
que es igual a 5 más x es igual a 5 x
ahora hemos despejado y para que donde
aparece y en la otra ecuación
sustituimos 5 más x ahora la otra
ecuación es la voy a poner aquí en
naranja 9 x + 3g es igual a
cuando despejamos ya de la segunda
ecuación encontramos que es igual a 5 x
así es que podemos sustituir ya de la
segunda ecuación con 5 + x
de esa manera garantizamos que estamos
cumpliendo con ambas restricciones
hagamos eso en vez de ye sustituyamos 5
+ x entonces esta ecuación resulta en 9
x + 3 en vez de llevó a sustituir 5 + x
es decir 3 que multiplica a 5 + x y esto
es igual a 15 resolviendo ahora para x
esta ecuación tenemos 9 x + 3 x 5 15 + 3
x x 3 x esto es igual a 15 voy a agrupar
los términos en x del lado izquierdo que
son 9 x 3 x es 12 x + 15
12 x + 15 es igual a 15 vamos a despejar
la x restando menos 15 a ambos lados voy
a restar 15 a ambos lados entonces que
nos queda esto se cancelan y nos queda
del lado izquierdo tan solo 12 x que es
igual a 0 dividiendo entre 12 ambos
lados esto se cancela y nos queda que x
es igual a 0 deja de bajar un poco x es
igual a cero si x es igual a cero
cuánto vale y podemos sustituir en
cualquiera de las dos ecuaciones que
tenemos acá arriba sustituyendo x igual
a cero en la primera ecuación que no
resulta 9 x 0 + 3 porque es igual a 15 9
x 0 es cero y nos queda tan sólo tres
igual a 15 dividiendo entre 3 ambos
lados nos queda estos términos se van y
nos queda del lado izquierdo y jay del
lado derecho 15 entre 3 que es igual a 5
igual a 5 podemos ver que también cumple
con esta ecuación 5 menos
pero es igual a 5 así es que los valores
lo voy a hacer en verde los valores x
igual a 0
igual a 5 cumplen con ambas ecuación es
así que ya hemos hecho la primera parte
hagamos la segunda parte gráfica hemos
la segunda ecuación se puede graficar de
inmediato de hecho ya está en su forma
igual a mx más b de hecho no exactamente
déjame intercambiar x con 5 para que que
en su forma igual a mx más de esto sería
entonces igual a x más 5 la ordenada al
origen es 5 1 2 3 4 5 y la pendiente es
1 aquí está implícitamente un 1 está x 1
la x así es que la pendiente es 1 la
recta sería más o menos así déjame ver
que también me sale aquí sería esta
recta si avanzas a la derecha uno sube
es uno si avanza a la izquierda uno
bajas uno
no está tan mal ni recta así es que esa
recta corresponde a esta ecuación ahora
graphic hemos la ecuación de arriba
primero lleva la ecuación a su forma
igual a mx más b su forma pendiente
ordenada la voy a reescribir en verde 9
x + 3g igual a 15 notamos que los tres
términos son múltiplos de 3 así es que
vamos a facilitar las cosas dividiendo
entre 3 la ecuación dividimos entre 3
cada uno de estos términos y nos queda
3x más y es igual a 5 ahora restando 3x
a ambos lados préstamos 3x ambos lados y
que nos queda nos queda y es igual a
menos 3 x más 5 hemos transformado la
primera ecuación a su forma pendiente
ordenada ya igual a menos 3 x 5 vamos a
graficar la la ordenada al origen es 5
ahí la tenemos y la pendiente es menos 3
si te mueves uno a la derecha bajas 3 si
te mueves 2 a la derecha baja 6 2
462 a la derecha bajamos 6 y tenemos los
puntos vamos a unirlos para tener el
trazo de la recta y ahí la tenemos y
como puedes ver la solución del sistema
es el punto de intersección de las dos
rectas es la pareja xy que cumple con
ambas ecuaciones esta recta violeta son
los puntos de coordenadas x que cumplen
con la ecuación
x igual a 5 la recta verde comprende los
puntos de coordenadas x y que cumplen
con la primera ecuación ahora el punto
de coordenadas x que cumple con ambas
ecuaciones es el punto de intersección
lo encontramos algebraica mente por
medio del método de sustitución x igual
a 0 llegó a las 5 x igual a 0 el eje y
llegó a la 5
ahí está